et moi ça sera bowl en 2000 j'étais
contente toi de livres l'an 2000 oui tu
vas lviv tu vas voir ça passera l'an
comment ça va être tout va changer
tout aura changé depuis une maison de
passe difficile mieux encore les sols
l'eau ça on aura des lectures à s'en
faire et puis les trois journées ils ont
les ailes ils ont des réacteurs inoki
pense que ce sera magnifique
comment tu voi en 2009 à jouer avec des
souterrains beaucoup de bas ciel
beaucoup de ratés oui et je vois comment
les voitures pour se rendre sous terre à
terre et les gens comment sont ils des
gens bah ils seront ravis comme ancien
temps a dit chapeau haut-de-forme mais
moi ça serait bien en 2008 revient
et c'est une personne endormie
berne changer seront certainement très
différente du monde actuel comment ce
sera bien
la technique va prendre de plus en plus
d'expansion et va agir sur de nombreux
domaines sans doute dit mois d'après
vous ce sera beau l'an 2000 ben ça je ne
conçois pas du tout l'an 2000 étant
donné que maintenant j'apporte à beau
avoir le monde
pas toutes ces guerres les événements
maintenant tu seras pas beau nous
pourquoi j'espère des maisons partout le
codever duo d envoi des coins de verdure
quand même non pas du tout
l'an 2000 c'est irréel parce que j'ai
peur de devenir vieille et j'aurais 54
ans en l'an 2000 je n'espère pas les
avoir mais si je les ai j'essaierai de
vivre avec mon temps je suppose que le
progrès sera déjà bien loin de ce qu'il
y a maintenant et j'espère qu'on aura
fait beaucoup de choses encore pour les
enfants qu'on leur a donné quelque chose
un enseignement plus pratique que
maintenant pour le progrès ce sera
quelque chose qui deviendra un peu
inhumain qui sera encore plus loin nous
que ce que l'on fait maintenant c'est
pour ça que l'un 2000 ça me fait peur ce
sera en tout cas plus agréable que le
xxème siècle ou que notre époque
actuelle que les maisons même si ce sont
encore des grands immeubles seront
vitres et les aurait peut-être rallye
benoît et on pourra et sera plus
agréable à 8 et que certaines que
certaines cités immeuble maintenant un
peu près intenable commenté voit les
médecins en nombre
et sur quoi tient-elle sur la terre pour
les immeubles
je vois des immeubles en plastique gris
des gros blocs de plastique pour
fabriquer à l'avance et qu'ils
assembleront qui seront sous des combats
les maisons pour moi ce seront des
grands immeubles en verre
un peu comme au porteur texte rotterdam
je crois ou amsterdam s'est contracté à
la ville
oui mais avec des arbres et à s'espacer
que les hymnes à la maison comment
restera-t-elle maisons d'ouvriers bon ce
sera dans un gratte-ciel bastia rapide
du pavillon et un petit immeuble rien du
tout et tu seras trés haut comme ça
dépend la hauteur qui nous longerons
aura envie de quoi à ses propos pour pas
tomber vous savez une maison avec tout
et audi qui a maintenant je sais pas si
on peut envisager les belles maisons en
l'an 2000 et les rues autour des maisons
commencement terre n'aimera pas beaucoup
car des petites rues et vous passez par
la circulation à l'ancienne le fera
atterrir
ben les toits seront pleins on pourra
circuler sur les toits puis dans les
rues dans le véhicule ce sera une espèce
de voitures avec des formes assez pointu
qui qui avancera sur un coussin d'air et
bien comment sans carburant parce que tu
vois comme carburant du carburant un
gars qu'on trouvera sur la lune mais moi
tu vois un véhicule pour l'avenir oui
une espèce de petite sphère avec une
bille à la base qui tournerait qu'au
bout de cinq ans près partout
seulement partout enfin ça irait aussi
dans les airs est-ce que tu bois une vie
extérieure à la planète terre oui mais
ça me paraît très possible puisque
maintenant ils disent astronautes
mais c'est effrayant pourquoi parce que
les âmes semble des hommes sont devenus
des estivants dans la lune je crois que
qu'il y aura tomber une une coopération
pacifique que dans la conquête de la
lune et des autres planètes mais j'avais
certainement au poignet une lutte pour
un con minutes sur la terre pour la
reconquête de l'espace non je crois que
celui qui découvrira ou qui mettra même
le premier le pied sur une planète sont
assurera la possession sûrement il y
aura la gare clé martial cercle des
planètes
teva des planètes extérieures à la nôtre
auris hernie mais comment vois-tu ton
voyage dans la lune imagine que tu
fasses ton service militaire dans un
groupe astral
comment ta voix tu habillé comme un
petit avis on sera bien que des
combinaisons anti radiations tomber
quelque chose comme ça et qu'est-ce qui
se battra les hommes de la terre ou des
hommes avec d'autres hommes d'ailleurs
tous trois hommes d'ailleurs est ce que
t as peur de la guerre enfin nos un peu
moins peur des braqueurs à la guerre
mais qu'est ce que tu vas toi
aulas
mais ça me fait pas peur
o la guerre à l'est pourra sans doute
pas être supprimé si la technique ne
s'agit pas les hommes et va dans le sens
de la violence il est certain que les
guerres pendant de plus en plus
d'ampleur est-ce qu'elle progrès te fait
peur oui et non le progrès donnent une
nette amélioration sans doute dans la
vie dans la vie de l'homme de tous les
hommes par contre il peut conduire à des
à des excès qui sont 12,5 millions
justement par la guerre qu'est ce qui te
fait peur dans l'avenir et bien ce qui
me fait le plus peur c'est le manque de
modération que peuvent avoir les hommes
ne seront pas contenir tout ce qu'ils
trouveront pas la fin du monde si à la
guerre maintenant avec avec les bombes
qu'ils existent tu dois pas cela c'est
un terrible parce que comme on sent
certainement dans l'ère atomique sicile
gens font la guerre et bien ils
détruiront tous touchent plutôt au
contraire que et il verra plus dure et
rapide guerre non enfin les moyens de
destruction sont telles que finalement
la gare sera plus possible
je crois que
vers l'an 2000 l'europe pourra sera ou
aura tendance à s'unifier
[Musique]
l'europe peut-être le monde
6 s'il est prouvé que nous aurons à
faire à d'autres
à d'autres via d'autres sociétés dans
les planètes peut être une union de les
états de l'europe est en tout cas une
inégale une égalité dans tous les pays
qu'il y ait puissance égale un équilibre
dont sur toute la terre comment vois-tu
les gouvernements sur la terre des
gouvernements démocratiques et qui font
régner la plus à la paix politique
c'est pas utile
je m'intéresse pas je sais pas comment
ça ce rat mais moi je voudrais que je
pense est libre comme on puisse
s'exprimer comme on veut qu'ils pas de
différence de classe c'est qu'on conçoit
libre vu que tout le monde sera libre
encore fermement pour le monde entier de
la terre jean-michel le logiciel monnaie
moi je crois que il n'y aura pas de
gouvernement
internationale y aura toujours une
division entre pays mais peut-être
certains petits pays dix pirates ont-ils
pour se fondre en fédération j'aime à
des pays où un pays un seul un seul
qu'est-ce qui veut perdre at monde
l'amérique la chine amérique chez pas
parce que je pense que quand même la
russie c'est quand même un pays avec qui
a de l'avenir quoi qu'est-ce qui va le
diriger
puis hier chez toi ça sera oui c'est un
américain un français un anglais un
riche et où tu le vois ce gouvernement
du monde où est-ce qu'ils s'installent
en la france très piège se trouve très
visuel très shell ni arabes est l'état
ça sera un régime de quelle forme
liberté sans hâte liberté une liberté
bien dirigés oui est ce qu'elle cherche
à un militaire ou un civil un civil
ces villes parce que l'armée y aura une
grande importance
oui est ce que tu vois des pauvres des
riches bon à mon avis beaucoup plus de
riches à ceux comme ils font des études
ils ont ils auront tous une bonne
situation
bien sûr peu raté journée pour fédérer
ça changera pas
mais qu'est ce que tu seras
pauvre
oui toi qu'est-ce que tu seras un patron
ou un ouvrier j'espère qu'un patron te
des galettes ouvriers je travaille je
donne mon pays
est-ce que ça va marcher la vie dans un
patron il y aura pas de patrons ou quoi
pas de patron ce sera toi le patron bien
aller pas ton cas
puis des ouvriers ça c'est obligé comme
pigalle rouille et toi qu'est ce que tu
seras là dedans au choix pour vous voyez
comme commun non pourquoi pour ouvriers
ci pourra pas voir comment aller pour
apprendre tout ça est ce qu'il ya des
patrons pour toi là on n'aime pas je ne
pas les patrons gemlik tout le monde
fait de galles haïku quoi mais c'est à
dire que il y aura plus de patron et
moins d'ouvriers communiqué tout se fera
automatiquement et qu'est ce que tu
aimerais vivre dans un monde de bâton ou
un monde ouvrier départ tron et toi
qu'est ce que tu serais je serai pas
trop et aurait pas d'ouvriers aussi
apple nous pas beaucoup et rappelé de la
chine le patois l'avenir est acquis à
l'ouvrier ou aux patrons baal ouvriers
n'ont pas à tous les hommes
[Musique]